pour claudio quel futur secrétaire
national du parti de gauche spécialiste
de l'amérique latine
l'accord entre l'union européen
européenne et le mercosur beau être
abandonné les différents députés de la
france un service comme tout de suite
dénoncé cette marche en avant de cet
accord qui est un accord contre les
peuples
non seulement il a été fait de façon
totalement opaque puisqu'il ya une
certaine opacité dans ce sens est dans
cet accord on sait vraiment pas question
qu'est ce qu'il y à 2 2 font jusqu'au
jusqu'au bout mais en plus on a dénoncé
dès le début les conséquences que peut
avoir pour le pour notre environnement
pour notre planète est pour et pour les
gens pour les habitants de notre de
notre sueur sur cette planète donc dès
le début on s'est prononcé on a dit
qu'il ne fallait pas aller plus loin sur
sur cet accord et vont regarder
autrement les questions des changes au
niveau 1 au niveau international on doit
plutôt réfléchir sur des intégrations
deux peuples et non pas d intégration de
bien sûr des réflexions qui dépasse un
peu haut ce qu'on a
le lexique classique et traditionnelle
de libre échange de commerce et de
choses qui n'ont plus lieu d'être